das einfach dann nur noch warten bis ich
gelandet bin derweil könnten wir endlich
mal hier mit viel schwung ins wasser
springen
gray davis s kids und herzlich
willkommen zur ersten folge geht online
heißt und wir haben heute eine
bärenstarke groupe e sa 4007 gianluca
ist am start 19 dann tomekk hallo wenn
die meisten von euch wahrscheinlich auch
schon kennen und neu in der runde
michael frieser hallo wer hier in gta
online searches leute bevor es losgeht
wollte ich euch noch kurz sagen dass ich
momentan gar ein bisschen probleme mit
minecraft habt und zwar immer wenn ich
in die server liste gehe pingen alle
server und nach einer weile steht der
kundenkontakte schon mega viel
ausprobiert firewall
da war alles die installiert punkt
minecraft ordner gelöscht vielleicht
habt ihr eine idee schreibt die
kommentare rein
wir spielen jetzt zum heißt ich wünsche
euch viel spaß so da sind wir eben heißt
hier können wir gerade mal unsere
klamotten auswählen
aber okay da unser team aus ich glaube
ich muss darüber reden zu den piloten
es droht ein pilot reicht okay im
heutigen heißt leute müssen wir ein
flugzeug clown darum stets das gehört
zum gefängnisausbruch heißt und der
auftrag lautet steht ein flugzeug der
wahl schmuggler auf dem erkennt die
flugfeld es benötigt um raschkowski
denen müssen wir beim ausbruch helfen
nach dem gefängnisausbruch außer landes
zu schaffen und dazu haben erzählt drei
polizei schützen und da eben den piloten
soweit alles easy getuntes fahrzeug ok
911 ist mein audi a8 habt ihr schon mal
gesehen habe da wird man sehen
aber ihr werdet ihn sehen mich gesetzt
der jungs
ich kann einen mitnehmen ja das ist
übrigens mein auto leute der mit wir
begeben uns zum was für ein auto gekauft
du hast in dem es vor sich als bonus
bekommen rennen wer als erster am
flugzeug ist er kennt sich flugzeit ist
der sänger und gewinnt eine kiste äpfel
aber das klappt lässt erzählt im
hintergrund wieder was ich weiß wie der
wagen ist ausgebrochen
die andere komponenten ich hab keinen
platten gesorgt hatten war so komisch es
zieht sich nach rechts nee ich hab glaub
ich keinen platten vielleicht oder nicht
die hast nicht
es geht erzählt etwas über die wago
leute da draußen sie das gewusst
weltweit aber unsere platzierung ist
bisher recht gut da hinten ballast über
bord werfen können ok alles da ist
eigentlich unnötig aber ich habe gelernt
gerade wenn man mit dem auto mit dem
audi abkürzung verkauf wackelt nicht so
schlecht
jetzt nicht ausbrechen nicht mehr mit
läuft leute in alkmaar diesen rot auf
der karte markiert die wollen ja da
wollen wir keine zeit leute werben heißt
zu erledigen so wie ich mir das im
allgemeinen vorgestellt habe leute mit
dem heißt ist wie folgt wir werden das
wahrscheinlich so machen dass wir immer
mal wieder zwei gäste einladen hierzu
den heißt beziehungsweise wir machen
erstmal in der konstellation der heißt
hier fertig und wenn wir einen neuen
heißt starten es gibt ja insgesamt will
heute sein glaube oder 55 gibt ok 5
heißt das heißt man kann fünf
verschiedene teams die hst und zb auch
mal zuschauer dazu einen namen gemacht
in gta sicher auch ganz witzig oh gott
das wir schon wie der baum sie einfach
untergepflügt
ich würde sagen leute dass lukas ein
gepanzertes auto wie steigen zustand der
dinkel schießen schon rein dar ein 33
jähriger rheydter auftakt das ist ja
nicht die luft jagen online einfach
einfach rein fahren
das geht schnell frischen dankbar ich
vielleicht doch da vorne rein
sagt explodiert auch okay jetzt dahin
kommt meinte glaube ich mit dem
schnellsten auto wahrscheinlich hält
autostadt ist auch die schwarze
beleuchtung und du weißt das gute zeug
ok ich müsste erstmal einiges kind
lieber erst gar nicht getroffen wird
falls es per genickschuss gestorben
starb an einem kniestoß halte wie viel
ihr noch sind
watermann stück vor wir erledigen wir
das alte was los gefolgt
eine komische leute hier sind es gibt es
ja nicht dass sie ordentlich was hier
abgeht auf welche schwierigkeit spielen
wir nicht diese qualität aber das gehört
überhaupt getroffen ich im auto ist mega
gut so sagt man ist passt nicht heute
ist auch noch ein viertürer als optimal
okay meinte kommt so klar wir müssen
weiter helfen drüben karabiner
schutzweste ja ach du scheiße da viele
so langsam und nicht ab
ich weiß nicht kannst du abheben bevor
wir alle ausgeschaltet haben
theoretisch geht das schon ich weiß es
nicht wo schießt die robert ausschnitt
im katalog folglich leute vor sich
defensiv wir haben nur ein team leben
wir jetzt noch eine stütze daraus
aufpassen
ok wo bist du kollege hier irgendwann
auch in bar
es sind richtig viele wartet ich die man
in den texten deckung ok weite hätte
locker
da probiere einfach zu stark macht ein
ding wir sind der bank am rhein
probier's profis presst kommst du kommst
natürlich siehst du eine chance
irgendwie hin
alle sind das viele alter schwede was
soll mittelfristig in rot
ok ok ok dass viele leute alters später
sei es daten und sehen uns gleich hier
wieder so vielleicht war auch einfach
erstes komplette flugzeug fliegen da ist
weg ja aber wie wir das machen machen
machen machen das kind einrichten
strategie weniger fragen mehr machen wir
machen weiter und jetzt steigen wir alle
bei gianluca in den gepanzerten coruna 1
denn da geht es richtig ab auf dem
flugfeld ich glaube wir spielen sogar
auf schwierigkeit schwer kann das sein
okay aber normal ist hab ich noch besser
bei unserem ersten heißt alles danach
fahren zwar darüber bringen also wieder
voll rein fahren oder saure ich glaube
leute macht einen planer zudem durch ok
dann ist okay jetzt gibt's von rein
aus den ersten tieren
vielleicht muss ich jetzt hier schnell
herz machen die alle mitnehmen da kommen
ja immer welchen er komme der content
seien und eine ganze zeit jetzt klar
probier mal rauszugehen
das ding ist müsste eigentlich raus
gehen bevor die das flugfeld zu fahren
da ja gut so die wehrmacht felix
tierpaten und nicht mehr geheim
ich werde überhaupt nicht getroffen das
richtig kasse vollhardt okay okay doch
so wenn ihr rechts noch ganz viele
islamisten setzen das geht gut voran
fall ist kommt jetzt noch einmal
verstärkung 22
gut dann probieren das noch die werden
eben noch mit hier seid ihr bei der
finanzierung seiner kommt der aber nicht
nachladen
ich kann ich nicht ausschließen
okay wer hinten auch noch ok sehr schöne
session sessions geht voran die wahl
ausgehen
hier ist noch ein auto auf der rechten
seite neuer kann also genau das auto ist
so krass kein google dich sie einfach so
eine oberfläche wie ein golfball aber
okay ich krieg rp fürs fahren mit
anderen spielern sehr nice hier drüben
kommt noch mal ein auto aber es hat noch
1 hinten läuft da hinten fahren auch
noch zwei okay lasst uns das auto noch
mitnehmen von kurz bisschen raus handy
kaputt machen kommen gebiet und feuer
vielfahrer star war jetzt noch ich
glaube jetzt kommt keine verstärkung
mehr kann es sein alle coma ist auf
jeden fall richtig gut
luca zum flugzeug und wir ich nehme den
ideen sperlings wir fahren die fahrzeuge
aus dem weg die wähler wurde von tesa
film ein gesamtpaket kann sehr gut
nein
wir haben flug ich darf doch wohl ihr
parken oder hast du probleme hast wohl
haben ein problem
komm flieg ab kennt mich an die
praktische dranhängen ein okay wir
verlassen das flugfeld okay dann nehmen
die koma wieder weitergehen
kleine reinen da rein da ist toreck drin
einfach nur verlassen mccanns flugfeld
verlassen ja okay das ist nicht schwer
das können wir glaube ich im auto
aussieht gar nichts mehr business
einfach dann noch warten bis sich
geladen
derweil könnten eigentlich mal mit
vollem schwung ins wasser springen
schraub schraub schraub schraub schraub
schraub nein nein das auto es ist mir
laufen schnell hoch zur straße brauchen
wir so am fahrzeug ich hab gerade mein
persönliches fahrzeug zerstört alter wo
okay wie einen baustopp bis zur
ablieferung bewegung
ich muss ja bis zum flugplatz war das
anders also den großen erzielt keine
ahnung
minute oder so jetzt will ich hier gar
ein bisschen karambolage ich mich auf
die reifen und schließlich noch ein
randgeschäft
es hat leider nicht das schnellste ist
kleine [ __ ] nahe den runtergeholt
erhöhen wette ist und beim motorrad kann
schiessen nine inch eskalierte schließen
aber ich bin müde dies nicht schuld sich
wieder das fahrrad nähe des motorrads
mit großes verdienst du bereitest du
bereitest du bereitest einigkeit
81 wie ist einfach nicht funktioniert
ok hast du ihn erwischt nein er lebt
sogar noch okay steckt ja noch das
bleibt nicht aus vorne runden das gerne
auch noch oben wenn sich das gefallen
hat die folge statt auch gerne noch
verbesserungs clips rein wie gesagt ist
die erste folge online heißt sich hier
für euch mache was herr rothe vom
flugfeld gibt gast gast gast
das repertoire jungs älter bist okay
leute ja gerne verbesserungsvorschläge
in die kommentare
er warte noch darauf dass die mission
beendet wird okay das auto geht kaputt
oder kannst du fahren
die schraube gar so nice wie viel haben
ein projekt aufbau west
alte wie denn die braucht easy okay fand
er ein spätzünder okay
mein weg weg weg ich weiß nicht woher
ich weiß nicht wohin halten zu werfen
ohne wird sich glaub die wir unter uns
hoch gegangen und dann wenn wir beide
tot
und hätten wir eine mission verloren der
weiterhin verwehrt bleibt
ich wollte die waffen wechsel scheiße ok
ausgleich geschafft pauli flugzeug
abgeliefert und jetzt und wir warten
weiterhin müsste produktivität eiskanal
hey hast du hast die abgeliefert oder na
ja bei mir steht wartet bis der pilot
yvan abgeliefert hat ja ich hab das den
zugführer ist drauf und die erste
vorbereitungs mission ist geschafft
silber was wahrscheinlich lukaku fair ja
wie gesagt was wir witzig gefallen hat
das gerne daumen nach oben
egal welche ideen ihr habt um diese
folgen hierzu besser zu gestalten weiter
zu entwickeln schreibt sie gerne
kommentare wir sehen uns wieder haut
rein macht's gut und